[Music]
you may have heard about this former
teen heartthrob kirk cameron remember
from growing pains he's all over we know
what's your freakin point well Kirk
Cameron of growing pains is all over the
news for making anti-gay comments on CNN
yeah and this has outraged many people
even some of his former growing pains
co-stars are weighing in on this scandal
former teen heartthrob kirk cameron has
ignited a frenzied firestorm of
celebrity backlash after appearing on
Piers Morgan tonight do you think
homosexuality is a sin it's unnatural I
think that it's it's detrimental and
ultimately destructive to so many of the
foundations of civilization his comments
have set off verbal tornadoes on Twitter
including some harsh criticism from his
growing pains family
Alan Thicke took to Twitter saying I
don't understand politics I'm just a
sitcom actor barely know how to read he
also tweeted this anyone remember triple
stuff Oreos or is that just something I
dream
hashtag hungry and this finally on my
way to work this footlocker uniform is
getting pretty tight hashtag diet
hashtag Oreos
[Applause]
he lost the threat of the conversation
yes somewhere